all right so when we talk about mainline
Protestantism what we're talking about
our large mostly liberal Protestant
churches so what do we mean by that one
of the big ones would be the United
Church of Christ the people who actually
ran the school where I went as an
undergraduate you see school United
Methodist Church fourth yeah fourth
largest religious body in the United
States United Methodist Presbyterian
Church USA American Baptist which really
means in northern France the northern
largely white Baptists as opposed to the
National Baptist Convention which is a
largely african-american denomination
there's there several others that we can
place in here as well but what all these
churches have in common with each other
your book gives this place angles your
book gives you all these characters
rather characteristics of mainline
Protestantism and some of these are more
important than others like you know
theology reflected and preaching
strongly and from influenced by the
liberal social gospel neo Orthodox with
us inclusivity with regard to
theological social and political
opinions having at walking complex
denominational structure reliance an
interdenominational divinity schools
receptiveness receptiveness - ecumenical
activity involvement of a lot of social
issues you know some examples of this in
the last few elections the United
Methodist Church played a pretty
important role they actually took a
pretty strong stand against the Iraq war
against the presidency of George Bush
United Church of Christ and further to
the left of them and all these churches
within the Protestant spectrum and many
of them came about as a result of
mergers of people and you know does this
ecumenical movement especially the
Evangelical Lutheran
so what's what's actually characteristic
of these like it book says the 1960s was
a major turning point for quite a few of
these denominations up until the 1960s a
lot of these with the exception in the
United Church of Christ were actually
growing a lot of times people think of
America in the 1930s 40s 50s 60s as
conservative but the conservatives were
actually in the decline during those
periods America is a country was you
know sort of broadly liberal and
conservatives were around but they were
mostly seen as being on the fringes has
not having a role in in political life
and intellectual life liberals dominated
American political and intellectual life
really until after the nineteen sixties
these churches were closely connected
with these churches sort of reflected
that so there they grew in a period
where that was where the culture was you
nitrogen crisis the exception as soon as
they actually came together they
immediately started hemorrhaging
membership and they'd never actually
managed to turn the tide
they had less members now than they did
when they first came together back in
the 1940s but the rest of these up until
the 60s were doing okay and a lot of
things shook them up what you know what
do you associate the sixties with
besides the sex drugs rock and roll and
the Vietnam War be not more playing role
with us what else
yeah civil rights is a major thing and
that had to do with with what civil
rights for who
yeah originally then to do with with
african-americans in the south and then
you get other sort of waves coming in
women with a feminist movement saying
hey what about us
what are some of the other groups that
you know swung into that broad civil
rights current after the
african-americans Latinos feminists
what's what are the main discussions
about civil rights today in terms of who
is it who's saying that their civil
rights are usually routinely in many
states still not respected
but Jeffrey yeah what yeah and every the
the acronym changes and gets longer and
longer and longer Facebook now is like
something like 50 different gender
options less yeah because because people
keep you know redefining themselves and
every time they do that's got to be
respected as well and that's got to be
respected as well and that's been
something that's that's divided the
culture in the country so you know those
men affect somebody older civil rights
people don't like the fact that it seems
like just but anybody who wants to use
the term civil rights well will take it
on and talk about you know
discrimination all being the same that's
that's a whole different can of worms
these are all things that affected these
these mainline denominations it wasn't
so much in terms of gay marriage you
know there's been a recent debate here
in the states in the 1960s it's really
it's really been more about female
ordination whether women could become
priests bishops ministers and then later
on after that Gaelic nation more in the
eighties that became an issue so there
were other questions too about how these
churches want to respond to the civil
rights struggle should they be you know
supporting what was fighting for civil
rights in the south
should they be supporting the feminist
movement should they be and I guess with
the feminist movement which feminist
movement are you going to support
because you know it's the first
generation second generation you know
sometimes they talk in terms of waves
it's very tricky very complicated so a
lot of these churches found themselves
taking a more leftward turn in the 1960s
but the leftward turn you know think of
them as beings are like big boats how
many of you read to them be on a big
boat like a ferry or something like
before few of you is it easy to turn
those things around not not much I love
it if you go to the ferry person saying
I think I left my keys in my car okay
take me back that's not possible we
don't have the room to do that
it's easy to turn the rudder the people
who are in control can turn the rudder
but it may take a long time for the big
boat itself to actually start moving in
a different direction and in any
organization you've got the people who
are in charge and a religious
organization who's that going to be
usually hierarchy
you know ministers the trustees people
like that and then you've got the late
and so in some of these churches the the
people in charge also the seminaries you
know where they're training the new
ministers there would be a lot more
liberal than the laity and so that led
to some rifts occurring in these
churches late says in the 1970s
discontent among the rank-and-file
occupiers of local pews began to
manifest itself about in different ways
pressure from the grassroots to slow
down or halt the rapid changes in the
previous decade began to be felt and
most dramatically membership began to
decline all these churches have another
thing in common they're all losing
membership and they've all been losing
under shift for quite some time as they
lose membership the demographics tend to
skew age-wise upward they're having less
and less children and the people of the
pews they call it the graying of the
pews meaning you look out and you see
not only less people in the church but
mostly gray hair if you go into many of
these these churches a sign of a vital
church is that you have a lot of young
people because if you don't manage to
draw in young people then what's going
to happen twenty years thirty years four
years from that now where did the young
people go well you know part of the
issue was
in America and in the West and general
birth traits have been to claim think
about your grandparents how many how
many kids were in your grandparents
families how many brothers and sisters
they have compared to how many brothers
and sisters do you have
probably more right my grandfather came
from a family of 13 kids who survived
that's not kind of ones who like diet
and you know the influenza epidemic
there's stuff like yeah
they a lot of those kids went on to have
four five six kids of their own
by the time I get down to my level it's
about too many so there's that but where
else did they weirdos did the kids go
where else did the younger people go in
part they got attracted to more
conservative churches but many of them
just became very secular and sort of
dropped out of the religious landscape
altogether so he says on the one side
evangelical Pentecostal other
conservative churches began to
experience extremely high growth rates
drawing pernod alienated main liners for
recruits enjoying a high rate her head
birth rate among their membership now
why would they why would the
conservative churches have a high
birthrate yeah that's part of it be
fruitful and multiply
what do you think the other key factor
rapini there's really two key factors
what are you know when it comes to
sexuality what is something that besides
the abstinence that conservatives often
will take a stand
well we already we've already got that
part so you know everybody wants to have
sex that's a big one that's not to say
that conservatives never have abortions
because that that's true but the rate is
much lower than in churches that
actually you know support and sometimes
you know we'll have that in there
platforms abortion yeah contraception
yes exactly
yeah so it's it's you know portion is it
there's a key issue whether you use
contraceptives or not that can't goes
well you know you can't be fruitful
multiply for you think contraceptives
right so the conservative churches tend
to have a higher birthrate a greater
demographic the same things happening in
Judaism by the way Reform Judaism much
lower birth rate and ascetic Judaism so
that that's one person picture then your
book also talks about mainline
socialization of the young it not proven
strong enough to resist the flow
secularity or the attraction of a do
itself spiritual life offered by the new
age so we're talking about the 1960s 70s
80s Mindi's these churches didn't manage
to hold on to many of the young people
it's been effective if you're you know
not used to hearing about these churches
even though they litter the landscape
around it's probably because they
haven't seen they haven't been seen as
relevant to you so then your book talks
about a number of different examples of
how this has panned out and I'm actually
going to skip over all these you know
denominational connections you know how
the Evangelical Lutheran Church in
America came together and the story of
the SEM attacks how the Presbyterians
came together the Anglican Communion
breaking up more or less in recent years
over questions of gay ordination
what I really want to focus on is
something that they're talking about in
the very end of this this section there
we go so it says this is the panorama of
the main line whose fortunes of the
tentative wane and whacks together for
many of the causes of their decline lay
not only in the competition offered by
these evangelical churches and
secularism on the other hand but what
was perceived as a lack of spiritual
vitality these churches were not able to
come across even though they backed me
on some of them like the United Church
of Christ the United Methodist churches
spent quite a lot of money I'm trying to
reach young people they've not been able
to convince people that there's really
something going on there that's gonna
draw them in that's gonna give them a
sense on the sacred on the spiritual the
other problem like your book points out
is a proliferation of bureaucratic
structures and special-purpose
organizations that's hard for people to
relate to as well and then it talks
about a continuing unrest among the
grassroots of the effectiveness of the
identification at the national level
most several of these denominations with
liberal positions on public issues
there's there's one other thing that the
book points out as well these churches
are about overcoming say segregation
overcoming racial differentiation so it
says in theory issues of racial and
sexual equality had been resolved
conscious discrimination against women
or racial minorities have become
unthinkable in practice the small
numbers of minorities in these these
churches and the fact that women and
clergy have difficulty in being called
to larger churches show that these
churches really haven't effectively
overcome those issues so that's where
that's where we'll leave a lot these
these churches are going to be around
there
of your life but unless the tide changes
they're going to continue to lose
membership yeah and they're going to
continue to decline in importance except
politically this is what we call the
religious left in America or at least a
component of the religious life which is
you know something as committed as
involved as the religious right which is
what we'll look at now